The key to solving problems like
this is to figure out how does
the address breakdown into offset,
index and tag this.
Conflicts will occur, where different
blocks have the same index bits.
In this particular cash,
256 byte block size.
Means that there are 8
bits to the block of set.
In hex, conveniently,
that means that the least significant
two digits are the offset and
we can safely ignore those,
because they are not apart of the index.
Now we need to figure out how
many bits are in the index.
We have 16 kilobytes and
256 byte blocks.
The number of blocks in the cache
is this divided by this and
that gives us 64 blocks.
64 is 2 to the 6th.
So we need the next 6 bits here
to tell us what the index is.
The 6 bits will be contained
in the next 2 hex digits.
So for 56 hex, we can write
it out as binary, this is 5,
this is 6 and
we are interested in these bits here.
So we're really looking for, which
blocks of these have the same bits here.
Those that have 56, definitely
we'll have the same index bits.
So we will definitely have
a conflict here and here possibly.
But in order to actually
have a conflict,
it needs to be a different block.
This address here does not
conflict with this one here,
because they're actually the same block.
They have the same block number.
So this is not a conflict.
They don't have the same
place in the cache, but
they're actually the same block, so
it's not a conflict among blocks.
This, however is a different block
number that definitely maps to the same
index, so this is a conflict.
55 looks like this, these are the 6
bits, they're not the same.
So this block will not
conflict with the one here.
Finally, 16 looks like this.
These are the bits that we're
interested in and they do,
indeed match the ones of this block.
So this goes to the same place
in the cache as this and
it's a different block, because
this is 123416 and this is 123456.
So this will also
conflict with our block.